Hello.
If I sound dead and sad, and if I sound sick, it's because I am not okay right now.
Doki, why don't you just take today off?
I thought today would be the day I'd recover, but clearly my immune system has other plans.
For those who don't know, because you guys don't have a Twitter, which is very understandable.
I mean, Twitter's a fucking mess right now.
I mean, not right now, but it's been that way for a while now.
Also, waiting for my game to fully... waiting for the for the early access build to fully extract.
Okay, there we go.
Sorry, this is why we don't have our game yet.
All right, sorry, this is why this is why we don't have our game yet.
We're waiting for the gate, for the early access build to fully extract.
So it says here we're at 54 percent.
So I have seven minutes left.
Okay, so um this game, I don't know why it's 50 gigabytes because it's like a whole new file that you have to download at the NetEase website.
Um, so like I just have to, I just have to wait for that.
So I should have woke up at four and done it, but I took a nap and woke up at 4 30.
Um, because I was, I don't know, so I was, I'm sick.
I've been, I've been sleeping the whole day, most of the whole day yesterday and the day before.
And I don't know, when did I get sick?
I think I got sick like three days ago.
So like, I got sick after the day after Doki Amber Doge's birthday.
Um, so, so I woke up the day, I think it's because I went, I went outside.
I think I, my body ever since COVID, my body has not been okay.
My body, my body has like regressed as like, you know how like you, you know, you're, the human body has like built itself to be strong after centuries and centuries of being exposed to viruses.
Well, like my body has done the opposite of that since COVID started in a way where I became a bubble, a bubble girl, like a bubble baby for so long, where I was stuck inside for so long that my body was like, wow, bacteria doesn't exist anymore.
We don't have to focus on being resistant amongst viruses if viruses don't exist anymore.
So I feel like the last year my body was like, what are all these new things?
My body's just like, oh my god, like, like one bacteria like comes in and was like, hey guys, like inside my body and then all my white blood cells just fucking was like, are like, oh my god, take everything, here, take it all.
Because they're not, they haven't been exposed to like, you know, criminals in so long that they
forgot how the immune system itself.
So, um, time for bubble Tokyo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So like, I'm not doing okay.
I'm in maps.
If I'm being truthful to you guys, I'm not doing okay right now.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, sorry, I'm breathing.
I cannot breathe through my nose.
So you're gonna be like, love you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad spreading his allergies of everything over to you.
Hope rivals distracted from the sickness.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm like, I say one sentence.
I'm like, I feel like I ran a marathon.
I'm like,
Oh my god, I feel like a fucking pug genetically fucked right now.
Oh my god.
Oh, so like, um, I legitimately when I made my schedule yesterday, I was like, will I be good enough for tomorrow for the early access?
Because I was told that, oh, yeah, early access is coming out tomorrow.
And I was like, wait, do you think I could access it?
Like, will you, do you read your discord messages?
I was like, no.
And then I looked, I was like, oh my god.
I could do it.
Oh my god, I can, I can access it.
So I was like, yippee!
So, I'm sorry, I'm breathing so heavily.
I'm like,
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
Oh my god, okay.
And so I was like, in my dying breath, if I'm gonna die today, I, I, I want, I want my 4i was to be my last stream.
That's how I want to go out.
I want this to be my last stream on my channel.
That's how I want to go out, chat.
Doki, please.
No, Doki!
Anyway, um, um, but yes, I, I was like, on the day after Doki Amberdoge's birthday, I was like, why does my throat feel closed up?
I was like, oh, is that bad?
Oh, no, that's bad.
Maybe it'll be better later.
So like, when I woke up, I also bought like $130 worth of the, over the, like, worth of medication.
I'm like, obviously I didn't go to a doctor because I'm Canadian.
Canadian problems right now.
So I just, I just uber eat some over-the-counter meds.
Did you guys hear that?
Wow!
I bought like three different forms of time.
I did not mix my medication!
I'm just testing them out every like, um, every day.
So like, day one, I'll try this medication if it doesn't work.
Day two, I tried this other.
Yes, I uber-eated my medication because I didn't want to go outside.
Doki Amberdoge is also at the babysitter right now.
So like, I literally woke up and I was like, I can't walk my dog.
I legit am barely surviving right now.
Because like, day one of the, no, no, no, no, no!
It's more so of like, because like, these are, it's just time though.
It's just time.
Oh guys, so like, I'm not mixing any medication guys.
I'm not, you always be popping.
No, no!
I'm not mixing anything.
It's legit.
These are like, you take them every four to six hours.
So I'm like, so I have like, so I have like, Tyenol for sinuses.
I have that one, which I'm taking for today.
And then yesterday, I tried out Tyenol.
I'm not a person anymore.
I'm, uh, the day, yes, I'm not mixing it!
I'm not!
Do not mix medication!
I'm literally, yesterday, I tried out the cough syrup, Buckley's cough syrup.
Which is like, fast relief of dry cough, sore throat pain, nasal and sinus, uh, uh, uh, yeah, that.
So like, there's, I tried that, um, and then, um, and then tomorrow, I'm gonna try out, I don't know which one I'm gonna try out tomorrow.
They're all Tyenol.
I'm sorry, I didn't buy Advil.
I tried to buy a different one, um, uh, and then tomorrow, I'm either gonna try Tyenol.
Sorry, they're all Tyenol.
Um, Just spin the wheel.
I'm gonna try out Tyenol rap action rapid or either Tyenol cold and sinus.
Today, I'm trying the Tyenol for sinuses.
But tomorrow, I might try to go wild and do the cold and sinuses.
So it's like both and I was like, well, I technically I do have both.
Um, It's all Tyenol.
No, no, no.
I have buckies right here.
Bucklies, you hear that?
I've got buck- I don't know if you guys hear me.
Whoa.
There's bucklies.
I have, I have bucklies right here.
I did that yesterday.
Um, oh my god, I'm not okay.
I- Okay, this isn't- okay.
So like I was telling my friend, I was telling my friend about how hard it is.
Also, I don't want to go- I don't want to line up.
It's either you go or you line up at a um, at a doctor's for like hours.
Um, Oh, sorry, I'm just trying to breathe.
Oh shit.
You know, my issues of why I can't go to the doctors.
And so and then they're like, oh I have a friend, um, I have a friend That's a doctor and then he could just prescribe you medication and like just like that.
I was like, is that illegal?
Okay, I don't need that.
I was like, that sounds like illegal as hell.
I didn't say who my friend was just that they know a doctor who like he calls up and be like, I'm sick and I can't go to a doctor right now and they just- okay, that's very illegal.
And then they were like, oh man, we could do- I could do that for you too if you want.
I was like, I don't know, that's all right.
I'll just- I'll just use my over-the-counter medicine.
Don't say that, this is very illegal.
How the hell do I- okay, I finished extracting it.
Please stop snitching on yourself.
I said no!
My rates.
Thank you for the self-report.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know my rights!
I didn't take the offer!
I didn't take it!
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
Oh.
All right.
How do I- how do I log in to the early access build?
Am I in?
Am I- Click to start.
Oh!
Oh, that's interesting.
Wow!
Okay, I'm not showing you guys this because I'm pretty sure I can't.
I'm not allowed to on how to log in.
Oh my god, it like boots me.
Okay, I shouldn't- I was gonna explain to you guys!
I'm sorry.
My brain has not caught- my mouth hasn't caught up with my brain yet.
I was- I was gonna explain to you guys what I'm doing.
Okay.
All right.
All right, there we go.
I was like, I'm pretty sure I'm not allowed to show you guys this in-house.
I was gonna- I was gonna explain it to you guys.
And so- Oh my god, I'm so fucked up, right?
Oh.
Let's see.
Uh, Mr. Zu- Um, Mr. Zu, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
I watched your VODs for the first time yesterday and fascinated with your cute laughing coolness and humor.
Please let me support you even a little from now on and I hope you get well soon.
Oh, your English is great!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Okay, let me- all right.
We got the game guys.
I knew- I knew we can stall long enough for this.
All right.
BAM!
Uh-oh, it should show up.
Whoa, you might be like, this doesn't look any different, but look at this.
Oh, wait.
No, sorry.
That's not different.
It shows- look at this!
There's some fucking tiger thing.
I don't fucking know.
Oh my god.
Look at that!
The torch and the thing!
Wow!
Okay, it should be like somewhere in here.
Where the fuck is- oh, there he is.
Look at him.
Flame on!
Okay, this guy looks- There he is!
The Fantastic Four's resident heartthrob.
Johnny Storm adds intense flair to every battle he fights.
Shrouded in warm flames, the Human Torch always manages to look cool while turning up the heat.
Oh, what are his skins?
Okay, is this from- oh, it's from the issue.
Oh, okay.
I mean, he looks really fucking cool.
Wait, what's this?
Negative zone gladiator.
Uh, came in just to hear you.
Med maxing.
Never change, Doki!
Never change!
Zero, thank you.
Give him a super chat.
Thank you.
DSP, thank you for the super chat.
D-Dragon, be honest with us, Doki.
Did you mix up the cost zero of anything else?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I swear, all I had was...
Tylenol.
I mean, all I do have is Tylenol and Buckly's, but like...
Tylenol- oh my god, I dropped my pill bottle.
All I had was Tylenol sinuses, guys.
That's all I had.
A certain- or do you want new rules?
Everything dies?
No, everything.
Oh my god, that's depressing.
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel.
I feel like his other skin is pretty boring.
But I bet- I guess it's just based off the comic.
Um...
Whoa, that looks- wait, I don't want to see on that skin.
I mean, that looks cool.
What was this?
Is this the MVP?
That has to be the other MVP.
This guy is scary against support.
This guy's gonna fucking kill me.
As a support player, this is the guy that's gonna fucking kill me.
All right, the attack I'm most scared about...
The guy- the thing I'm most scared about...
Is- is it this one?
No.
No, it's...
What the fuck?
What the- the Invisible Woman taps your power channel to fortify the entire- oh shit!
So all of them will have, uh...
Oh, all of them will have fortify.
This is the one I'm most scared of.
This...
Fully destroys Luna ult.
A Luna ult does not save you.
That means...
Majority of the support ults don't save you.
Oh my god, that is scary.
What do I do?
This...
Out-damages a Luna ult.
And if this out-damages a Luna ult, it means...
This can out-damage...
Mantis ult.
Storm of...
Invisible Woman ult.
And Cloak and Dagger ult.
Because...
Cloak and Dagger does not stack anymore.
What does that mean?
It means that...
In the past, um...
In this season, you can stack Cloak and Dagger ult...
And you just go back and forth, and then the healing stacks up.
But it doesn't stack anymore.
So like...
You're fucked.
But then you could be like, oh Doki, we'll just ban...
The Human Torch.
Well, like, that's for like Diamond.
Well, for you Diamond and for you guys who are below Diamond...
You can't do that.
Don't support no Diamond!
You're fucked supports!
Anyway, that means we're wasting another ban.
We're wasting, um...
No, I would ban the Human Torch.
The thing is, you have to ban both, because they're both seem really strong.
Because then, the Human Torch, because like Storm's damage boost is so fucking stupid.
Um, but you're wasting two bans on these two.
So that means you're leaving Wolverine open.
Okay, you're leaving Wolverine open, and you're, or you're leaving, uh, you're leaving, like, things open.
So there's a lot of fucked up issues here.
Oh my god, that's scary too.
People are gonna do fucking geometry on me.
Anything within the shape, you die.
So like, I'm gonna be watching some fucker playing Human Torch, doing shapes, fucking doing math on me, and doing simple geometry.
They're gonna be trying to draw a fucking shape on the floor.
And I have to like, I'll be like, looking on the floor and be like, is there a shape below me?
You can make a square, it doesn't have to be a triangle.
You can literally make, like, a square and everything.
I don't know how long, I don't know how long the flames exist for.
Watch out for the triangle.
Remember my trinometry.
That's what I'm scared about.
This is basically a boop.
Like, you boop people forward.
So, oh my god, I guess I had to deal with that.
What the fuck is this?
A bunch of fireworks that has created a flame field that's not dealing damage.
Another trigonometry?
Stop!
More shapes?
What do you mean there's more shapes?
How many times do I have to look at the floor?
I don't understand.
How many times do you require me to look at the floor?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, this is gonna be rough, guys.
All right, now we have the thing.
me in grade school learning geometry be like, all right, that thing.
Oh, he's difficulty one.
That's great.
He's apparently like Doomfist in Reinhardt.
Um, is unquestionably the rock star of any team he's on.
Or is that the forefront of the fight?
I cannot wait to see the Hulk and the thing, like, brawl it out.
That's gonna be so fun.
He is my man.
It's clobbering time.
It's gonna be so fun seeing the Hulk, then the thing just fucking just fight it out in the center.
Um Okay, okay and then his other his outfit is the trench coat.
Alice, don't care anything big enough to fit a man of your size.
I love how he has a little camera too.
Um, here's the thing.
Let me know, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I think this is a cool.
I think this is cool.
I think this cosmetic is cool.
Oh my god.
He's so fucking cool.
But what does it look like without the shirt?
Oh, you can see the rocks too.
Bro got the trip.
How about this?
Whoa, noir scars.
Oh That's so fucking deep bro.
Oh, that's funny.
All right, rocky jab.
I mean, it's basically a fighting game.
This is another hero for fighting game players.
It's clobber.
Oh my god, it's clobbering time.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
That's basically a rineshatter.
This is basically a rineshatter right there because you can see the stun and everything.
This is a doomfist charge, but then they go up instead.
Uh, so this is just the doomfist charge.
And there's the leap.
Jump towards your ally and apply damage reduction.
Oh, so like you get a little rock shield.
Oh my god, I don't know if I can play this guy.
I'm definitely gonna be throwing if I play.
A heavy blow.
Okay, that's a right click.
And what's my passive?
Immune to launch up, knockback, and other- oh wait, you can't get- you're- basically you can't get cc'd.
Oh, that's so cool.
You basically- it's basically Reinhardt, but like...
Reinhardt's wet dream.
It's his utopia.
All those Reinhardt players, you know, playing Reinhardt has always been like the worst thing ever.
Because you get cc'd to hell.
Like now, this is basically Reinhardt's fucking utopia where you can basically play Reinhardt with no cc.
Like, that's perfect.
My time has come.
Oh my god, it's finally here.
No, Wolverine?
Wait, that's true.
I wonder if Wolverine can kidnap him.
Oh my god, you can still sleep and freeze him.
That's true, but at least you don't get knocked back.
And launched up.
You know, 2 cc, like only 2 cc is alright.
What's causing fireball?
Oh, it's basically like picking up Hulk.
I wish you could pick up Raccoon and just throw him into the ocean.
The Raccoon will think that I'm here to help him and then I just chuck him off.
Oh,
the Wolverine can't kidnap him?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Okay, apparently the Wolverine cannot kidnap him.
All right, let's go to- let's go to- I have to be level- I'm not gonna be level 10.
I'm not.
Let's go to the practice range real quick.
Oh, I wish you can.
I wish they do a team up where you can just- No, we don't need to know.
I wish we had a team up where I can just throw Raccoon into the fucking- all right.
Oh my god, wait.
Are my settings- oh, I forgot.
My settings reverted.
Guys, what was my sentence?
I posted in my description, guys.
I'm too lazy to pull- I can't pull up my description.
Guys, what's my- Someone look at my description real quick and tell me what it is.
Okay, 1.83.
I was like, oh, this is not my sentence.
Oh fuck.
I don't have my- I don't have my reticle too.
I can- I can do my reticle real quick.
It's gonna be like the most scuffed ass reticle.
I'll just do default.
There we go.
That's fine.
It's really tiny though, but This is the best I could do.
Oh, reticle animation.
No animation, please.
I don't like animation on mines and I use green dot.
Do I use green or red?
No, I use green because I can see green better.
Um...
Oh my god, all right, this is awkward.
This is very awkward.
And then UI.
Uh, need healing.
Oops.
There we go, left control.
We don't have to go down as- Wait, but you're playing.
Guys, I don't need to go down.
I'll just look down.
That's how I'm gonna go down.
I'm just gonna look down.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right.
Like how- oh yeah, you're right.
It is.
It's like a little four.
Okay.
How do- okay, I think this is it.
I just have to draw a square.
And then...
Oh, wait, can I draw?
Wait, guys, wait a minute.
Wait, I can draw anything.
Wait, how far can this go?
How- no!
It's too fast, guys.
It won't let me draw what I want to draw.
No!
I can't draw a peepee!
At some point!
Oh, you're right.
You're fucking right.
I can do it fast.
Don't worry.
If I do this fast enough...
Guys, it's not looking like a dog!
Guys, if this is your peepee, go see a doctor.
I'm kidding.
If this is what it looks like, you gotta go see a doctor.
Look, I drew a pentagon.
Wait, I'm trying to- I'm trying- okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, simple geometry.
Look at that!
Oh my god!
Let's- we did it!
Wait, no, I don't think I can draw a star.
I'm trying to.
That's what I've been trying to do.
I can't draw- no!
I can't do a star!
It's too fast!
All I can do is draw the- Wait, can I draw a four?
Guys, does this look like a four to you?
Okay, wait.
Wait, do I go- I don't think I can go fast enough.
Okay.
No, no, I can't- I can't go fast enough!
Does this look like a four, guys?
Guys, do you think that looks like a four, guys?
Do you think I did it?
Does it know what a four- Guys, do you think I did it, guys?
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna kill these people inside.
There we go.
There we- whoa!
And I can just be like that.
Wait, what is this?
This one was a dive, right?
Oh shit, yeah.
Okay, and then this is where- I forgot what my super- oh yeah, the tornado!
Yeah, that's the tornado.
Oh my god, that is scary.
Not gonna lie.
Imagine all those tornadoes in that one support.
How big of an area can it cover?
Let's try.
Oh shit, okay, pretty big.
Wait, but it's not hitting.
Oh!
Okay, okay, wait.
Let's see how big of an area I can make it.
This, by the way, was no ability cooldown.
Wait, but it's not hitting.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, as long as I can do the shape.
But the thing is, I'm limited to three right now.
So that- I mean, I can still do that.
Look, I made a triangle.
Alright, so that's how you do it.
That's how you play- Um, that's how you play Johnny.
Okay, let's do- I did not need to go back to spawn to swap.
Uh, the thing is- What's the range?
Okay, oh my god.
Guys, look how far I am to Luna.
Oh my god.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait.
Oh my god, wait, how far can I be?
Oh my- Oh my god, what is my hitbox?
Okay.
Okay, so- Okay, here you go.
This is- Okay, this is how far I can be to Luna.
This is just my left click, by the way.
This is actually just my- my left click.
You can't escape the clobbering time!
You can't escape me!
Damn, okay, wait.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, wait, it resets if you hit somebody.
Wait, okay, wait.
Okay, oh no, right click is infinite!
Oh no, right click is infinite!
Oh shit.
Okay, right click is infinite then.
There's no cooldown for it.
Okay, and then E is the shield.
Get behind me!
All right.
Is my cooldown settings off?
Nope, it's not.
It's still- I- right click actually has no cooldown.
Nope.
Yeah, it's- yeah, ability cooldown- wait, yeah.
Right click has no cooldown.
That's- that's scary, actually.
Whoa!
My ride went dream!
See?
Shift has a cooldown.
The right doesn't.
There you go.
And then the Q is the shatter.
Okay, so that's the range for it.
It doesn't go to the- but that also means, like...
How is this range?
Okay, so that's the range.
The Q is kind of slow, but I feel like it's more so of a surprise thing.
And then just be like...
CLOBBERING TIME!
The ship also cancels movement abilities on stomp?
Oh, that is scary.
I need to time it correctly.
Get back over here.
Get back.
That's right, get your ass back in here.
Wait, how come I can't jump?
Why can't I jump?
Do I have to be like here?
Am I banned from- oh, I have- I can only jump if I'm next to an ally.
Ally.
Because I can't jump.
I'll have to look at the ally to be able to have the jump.
Oh, that's why.
Okay, that makes sense.
So here's the thing, in actual demo- demo don't try.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I can't jump unless I'm next to somebody.
All right, let's see.
How far is my jump though?
Okay, can I hold it?
If I hold it, will I- Okay, that's how far it is.
Guys, I'm not a good jumper.
Guys, guys.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I have to be on high ground.
Okay.
Guys, it's okay.
Okay, wait.
I have low mobility, but like how far can I jump from here?
All right.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, if- if I am below you, you're fucked.
If I'm here, sorry, you're fucked.
I won't be able to make it.
I'm sorry.
I have to be at even level playing field with you.
I- I have to- don't worry, as long as I have the high ground, you'll be okay.
Okay.
The thing's biggest mortal enemy is stairs.
Don't worry, the moment I get the stairs, I will save you.
Take me down.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm not tall enough.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
That's so much damage.
I'm a little scared because that looked like a lot of damage.
I have- I have the stairs, Anakin.
Don't worry.
I have the stairs.
That goomba stopped him.
Don't worry.
That's right.
Now that's a lot of damage.
All right.
All right, I guess we can do quick play.
Guys, I don't even know if I can- I'm gonna try to see if I can grab Johnny.
Uh, the human torch first.
I don't know if I can, but we'll try.
Absolutely destroyed by all the other streamers because like mostly it's streamers that- it's the streamers that have access to early access and in the moment I try to get the human torch, I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed by the enemy DPS player who's also on the human torch.
Oh shit, you're right.
Oh my god, that's right.
I have an assist.
My PC's faster.
My PC's just faster.
That's fucking right.
I have an SSD.
Get fucked.
That thank you hi-hat.
Wow, very impressive.
All right, we absolutely destroyed.
Okay, who am I playing against?
The faster SSD wins.
All right, okay.
Nobody I know.
Okay, that's good.
All right, I live gym lead.
I don't have descent because I have- I have to look down to fly down.
That's the only issue.
Because I'm always like, I'll never need descent because none of the supports have flying abilities.
So like it was never needed, but now I'm like, oh no.
Now that I have to fly, I have to look down.
My control- No, my control- my control is I need healing because that's more important to me.
My control is I need healing, guys.
I already fighted it.
Guys, this is- it's obviously more important, guys.
How are we going?
Okay.
Guys, obviously.
What if I make a shape now?
It's getting hilarious.
Let's just make a shape now.
Oh fuck, okay, okay.
Make another shape.
Go!
Just keep making shapes.
Let's go.
Get over here.
I just- I made a shape, guys.
All right, there.
Nice.
I need to like learn how to do, uh...
Draw a big cat!
Guys, do- Do you think that PP was not the first thing I did, guys?
Do you really think I would not- I wouldn't do a PP first?
Do you really think- Of fucking course I would draw a fucking penis first.
That's what society has taught us for years.
All I can do is draw a fucking square.
That's all I can do.
I can't believe I drew a fucking triangle.
Draw a goddamn triangle.
It's okay, I can draw another triangle.
Wait, what?
What are you doing?
What are you goddamn doing?
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
I'm gonna draw another triangle!
That's right!
Look at that!
Get in that triangle!
Simple geometry!
That's right!
That's fucking right!
I'll even draw another triangle!
I can't.
I have to get closer to actually do stuff now.
I- Okay, that's fine.
You know what?
That's right!
Get in here!
Oh my god!
What's going on?
I can't tell!
Nice.
I'll even draw a triangle again.
That's right!
What you gonna do here?
There we go.
Oh man, this is- I don't know what's going on, but it seems bad.
Guys, support players are fucked right now.
Everyone died and you weren't even- I just threw tornadoes and we won.
That's just dirty.
God!
I finally can burn the trees!
Life is beautiful!
Finally, my dream comes true!
I can finally burn trees down!
Oh my god!
Guys, I need to figure out like- Um, what was my other- Oh, what is my C ability again?
Um, oh, it's uh, it's that.
Okay.
I was like, what am I doing?
All right, now that I know now.
Finally!
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing it naturally.
How bad- That's right!
Don't make me draw a square!
Because I will do it!
Oh, I fucking- I fucked up.
I was not aiming at the wall.
I was- I was aiming at the- I will draw a square too.
There we go, that's right!
Oh man.
Wait, what are we doing?
There we go.
Did we get it?
Oh shit, we did.
Oh shit!
Okay, that's fine.
What's going on?
I don't know, but it's working.
Burn the tree!
Nice.
Get over here.
I'm fucking heading over.
Oh, you're gonna fall.
You're gonna fall.
Oh, Freddy.
Oh, goodbye Freddy.
I'm gonna kick you Freddy.
Get that tree.
Oh, you won't like this.
That's right.
Step on it.
Come on.
I know you want to.
Don't you want to step on it?
Boom.
Come on.
Goodbye.
Don't make me make a shape.
I- I- I fucked up the shape.
Oh my god, okay, where- where did he go?
All right, we're going to spawn.
I have the real deal.
Oh, Freddy.
Oh shit.
Who is this?
You think I won't?
That's right.
Just for you.
That's crazy.
Oh shit.
He also has a tornado.
Oh my god.
He's trying to kill our Venom.
Don't worry.
I made a really tiny triangle.
Burn the trees down.
Guys, do not worry.
I literally made the tiniest triangle possible.
Here we go.
I don't know if it hit anybody, but like, it's the thought that counts, you know?
Are they all gonna be okay?
I don't think he is.
You can't arm me.
That's right.
Get out.
It's so tight.
It won't see it coming.
Exactly.
I think those are bots.
I don't think Irish Smash Web YouTube was a bot.
I don't think.
I don't think bots have YouTube names, guys.
I think they were just really bad.
Freddy might have been a bot, but I don't think the people with the YouTube name were bots.
I don't think.
Bot games are three real.
Two bots versus all bots.
Oh my god.
All right.
Okay, so we might have versed against bots.
I don't know.
I don't know, but like, that felt nice though.
That felt really nice.
You can't just call people bots.
That felt good though.
Freddy might have been a bot.
This guy might have been real.
This guy actually had damage.
He could have been real.
Not gonna lie.
If anything, I feel like this one was a real person because he was trying.
Yeah, yeah, that seemed right.
Whoever was playing Luna was a real per- I think was a real person because they put- gave me orb instantly.
And like, if you're smart, you would give the person that's in the air orb.
So, yeah.
I- I don't think they were bots though.
I think these are everybody that's testing it.
Oh, yeah, I have enough to buy skins.
I honestly like the default Johnny, but like the thing, the- his suit, I think is cool.
I think this is cool.
I could buy that now.
Because I don't get to keep it anyway.
Oh shit, wait!
Can I?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
You don't keep this, by the way, so I might as well spend it.
I legit- I don't keep- I don't keep the skin.
This, like, this is not my account, technically.
Technically, it's not even my account.
It's like early access account.
So like, we don't get to keep it after early access is over.
So I might as well just spend it.
Guys, I think I did too well, so now they're trying to find me real players.
No, no!
No!
I did too- I bullied too hard!
So now they're finding me real players!
Sofiiiir!
It's not real!
No!
The SBO!
DMMK!
No one's doing Doom Quest?!
Oh my god, somebody come in.
So I can start- so I can start playing tank and free for all.
This is like my second time being here.
Please, somebody come in.
I need to beep someone up.
That skin is beautiful.
I think I like- Oh!
Oh nice, I got in.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Now they actually are trying to give me real people now.
Oh, yeah, I know these.
I know for sure some of these are real people.
Also, they're now giving you an option to- oh shit.
All right, I'm faster.
I have a faster SSD card than you.
There we go, that's right.
The better PC wins again.
We still haven't got like, uh, everyone's queuing.
Oh wait, is there the new map queue?
Oh shit, I was clearly not paying attention.
All right, we'll do the new map after this.
My solid state drive is fucking solid.
It's hella solid.
That's right, I'm fucking- I'm ready to beat someone up.
Oh my god, people know me?
I got famous.
Guys, guys, I'm wearing- no pictures, guys.
Only I can take pictures.
I have the camera here.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
I'm a rock star.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your laugh always brightens my day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, no pictures.
I'm incognito right now.
Oh my god, the trench coat doesn't work.
How could this be?
Don't worry.
You guys gotta- you guys gotta get near me so I can jump to you.
Oh wait, three second cooldown?
Oh no, no, okay.
No, it's not.
Okay, I was gonna be like, there's no way.
You're gonna run?!
Oh no, wait.
Hello?
I swear they will.
Get in there.
Wait, why did our other support fucking DC?
Guys, I don't know if I'm meant to be a tank player, guys.
Guys, guys, I don't think I'm meant- guys, what happened to our other support?!
What happened to my- heal me!
Heal me!
Don't make me play an actual hero.
Oh my god.
Please, I'm just- I'm just hitting.
Please, this is all I'm doing.
Our entire- wait, our entire lineup is like three melee characters.
Why don't we- why are you Iron Fist and not Storm?!
Holy shit.
The guy is Iron Fist and not Storm.
I'm like, did you not- oh, I got you, Johnny!
How am I gonna hit a guy in the air?!
How am I- they're both in the air!
What do I do?!
What the fuck do I do?!
This is actually not fair.
Like- oh!
Like, they're both in the air!
What the fuck do I do?!
They're both in the air.
This is actually not fair.
Holy- Oh my god.
Not your problem!
Not your problem.
That point too.
I literally can't do anything against him.
Literally not your problem.
The only person I can beat up is like- The only person I can beat up is literally the other tanks.
Like, I can't do anything else.
Like, I'm just like, who else?
Who do I beat up?
Who do I punch?
Oh my god, I punched a guy in the sky!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I'm just looking at the DPS.
I'm like, what do I do?
You're just there!
Oh my god.
Guys, this is what I mean.
Okay.
All right.
Now, I'll just run at the supports.
Okay, what?
What do I do when both DPS are in the sky?
Such is the life of a goblin.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'll run at the one support.
I can do this.
I'll charge into the one support and I'm just gonna be like-
This is it.
This is the- this is it.
Who's Japanese curry?
I just know that it's food.
Is he the number one captain of- what is he doing?
Captain America didn't even receive any buffs or nerfs.
What is he doing?
He didn't even receive any buffs or nerfs and he's still playing Captain America.
He got buffed?
Wait, really?
I should've read the patch notes more.
I read the incomplete leak version.
Guys, I read- Don't worry, I'm fucking- That's right!
You can't- you think you can disappear forever?
You gotta get out of invisibility soon to heal your team.
You think I don't know that?
Where are you?
Oh no.
No, where is she?
I wanted to fucking get her.
Where did she go?
I was trying to fight invis a woman.
She disappeared.
That bitch.
That fucking whore.
God damn it.
I know what you did with them.
Okay, okay.
Get out of here.
I'm gonna punch you.
I'm gonna- oh, I'm running away.
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm running away.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, he should not have anything.
Jesus Christ.
How are they still alive?
Oh my god, what did I do?
Oh, I got you.
I'm coming for you.
Where are you invis a woman?
I'm just gonna crap cat point.
Oh, no.
I still got it.
Fire's not gonna stop me.
But that will.
That's gonna stop me though.
That's gonna- yep.
That's gonna stop me.
Oh, I shark missed.
I shark missed.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Guys, please.
The point.
Only has it.
Only has Thor on point.
Has one person on point.
Are you all in the- oh, it's because the rest of our team is in the- is literally in the air.
That makes sense.
I was gonna be like, how?
How is like none of you on point?
And I realized it's literally because 80% of our team is in the air and not touching the point.
That is very sad.
That- Okay, but also incredibly funny.
Literally, no one is on point because of that.
Oh my god.
I'm just- Oh my god.
No, I wanted to get you!
I wanted to get you!
I almost got him!
Oh no, the comp clobbering.
The beatdown.
Guys, why does- why is tank- why do you guys play tank?
I don't understand.
What is it about tanks?
What is it?
What the- Guys, what- I'll eventually hit you!
That's it!
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, you whore.
You actual whore.
I'm gonna- I'm just gonna- I'm gonna- I don't care.
I just want to punch you!
Oh my god, they just walk away.
Look, I'm just trying to do my job, guys.
Don't resist.
We play tank because no one else would.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
My god.
All right, guys.
Now I know that I'm definitely not a tank player.
It's- okay, like, you play the thing, and your opponent is literally Storm and Johnny.
Like, I- I would swap.
I would 100% just swap.
I would not- I do not want to deal with that.
I literally look up in the sky and feel like I'm getting a fly swatter out and just trying to, like, hit him with a fly swatter.
You don't.
Because my other DPS were not hitting the other fly.
My other fly wasn't hitting the other fly.
Like, there's so many we don't need anymore.
Oh my god.
I literally was just looking up like, what do I do?
What do I do?
I'm like, get down from there.
I only swap targets when I found a fucking target that can't fly.
Like, what do I do?
He's just flying.
What do I do?
All right.
Oh my god, am I fast enough?
Oh no, this person's loading in faster.
No, I haven't downloaded Central Park yet!
No!
It's still faster.
So, so faster though.
That easy.
Haha.
I know these people are real too.
Passes hands in the west.
Didn't download Central Park, still got here.
Still managed to pick the character.
All right, oh there's the cemetery.
Oh yeah, so Blade is revealed here somewhere.
Welcome to New York, the most depressing place in the world.
In the Marvel Universe apparently.
Where do I go?
Oh, there it is.
True.
There's- who's that?
Where's this- is this the- oh, this is the zone.
Okay, I'm trying to figure out- oh my god, where am I?
Yeah, but according to Marvel, this is what Central Park looks like.
All right, I am ready to draw a square.
Okay, clearly I'm not.
Clearly I'm not ready to draw a circle.
All right.
That's right.
Boom, boom.
I'm literally just in the sky being annoying.
That's right, stand in there.
That's right, keep standing.
What are they doing?
Okay.
That's right!
Goodbye, supports.
Goodbye.
And then I'll make another square.
It doesn't matter because like- wait, where did they go?
Are they trying to go somewhere else this time?
Oh my god, where are they going?
I'm literally- time to make another square!
Oh shit.
Oh wait, they're over there.
Oh my god, I could have made a square there.
I could have made a square- wait, watch this.
Okay, I got- guys, don't worry, I'm a hero.
Guys, don't worry.
I've got that one guy.
I got the clone, guys.
Do not worry.
Okay.
There we go.
Triangle.
What should I- goodbye.
Goodbye.
I mean, good try.
Insane value.
Oh my god, what a square.
Okay.
Square!
How do I go from Japanese Korean number one captain America to this?
Like, how-
I'm not even gonna have a chance to explore the rest of the map.
Like, I can't believe it.
I don't even get a chance to explore the rest of the map, guys.
It's not fair.
Get out of here.
Why can't I- what?
Don't worry, I'll make a shape.
Keep you locked in.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
You can't get me.
I'm literally in the sky.
Wanna see?
Bro, I know we wanna see the map.
They're dying too fast for me to show you guys the map.
Stop being such a gamer.
Don't you make a cool- make a cool ass- Dude, fuck this.
Bro, fuck this Loki in particular.
Like- Fuck, guys.
He's like, where do I go?
Oh, you think- you think I won't make a fucking- watch this.
That's right.
There's a shape in there somewhere.
The triangles are so fast.
That's right.
I have a shape in there, I think.
Right there.
That tiny ass triangle?
That's my shape right there.
I'm gonna make more.
Fear the triangle, exactly.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna make more shapes soon.
When I make sure I need to not die.
Fear the tri- the tiny ass triangle!
Wait, it worked!
Wait, the triangle worked!
My tiny triangle worked, guys!
Did you see it?
Oh my god, my tiny triangle worked!
I knew it!
I knew it worked, guys.
I knew it.
I don't have to do it.
Now I know how they felt.
Now I know how they felt when I was trying to play the thing against this.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Fear the triangle.
Your ass is not pushing to the point.
How did I go from Japanese Korea to this?
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is this geometry?
Geometry.
See, map will save you in real life.
What the fuck?
I did more damage!
I got his money back.
All right, that's not fair.
I love the early access peak to the spawn area of this map.
It's not my fault!
They couldn't get to the point!
I tried!
It's not my fault!
I was on defense.
You think I'm just gonna let them win?
I was making triangles, chat!
I wasn't even trying that hard.
I was literally making shapes!
I was just making shapes, guys.
Please...
Your all-out storm gets so many kills.
You should have stopped ulting!
I was ulting!
I was just ulting one person!
I saw one person.
I was like, I'm gonna kill that one person.
Try and escape this!
She's just trying angles.
Oh my god, the perfect view of the triangle.
Duck, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
When Pythagoras was working on his theorem, bro was cooking something.
Those triangles are OP!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god.
That's actually, that's actually crazy.
You know, the craziest thing is that like...
Gamers don't look down or up, so...
I feel like this is gonna like, this is gonna be like a huge, a skill diff when um, it's gonna reveal Which gamers are actually aware of their surroundings.
Because the amount of times I walk into fire alone And like not even multiplayer video games too, like not even multiplayer games do I Do I like, I'm aware of my surroundings Because I walk in the fire all the time So there's gonna be like a huge like skill issue when the torch goes live
I mean, I don't even, I walk into fires on non-multiplayer games!
On games that like On games where the fire is even, is like ginormous on your screen and I still walk into it
So it's gonna be interesting to see like how many gamers don't actually, don't actually like look around Fire is map flavor dangerous?
That's crazy, duh Oh my god I think the hardest, I hope eventually Um, there is a lineup of like tank supports and oh, especially when Ultron comes out Ultron is gonna be a support flyer.
I hope eventually We're gonna get Enough heroes where we can build a team where they're all just flying characters I feel like, I don't know, I feel like that's gonna be fucking crazy Like a tank flyer We're gonna have an entire, we're gonna have an actual like air fight aerial battles and stuff Like we're gonna recreate Star Wars Yeah,
Ultron got leaked as a support character Um, where he has like nanobots or whatever fucking Uh, like does like heroes and stuff.
Hulk going to go swat, dragon ball fights
Try, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you NeoTriBeam.
Also flying tanks would be terrifying Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I cannot wait I cannot wait till you can actually build a full team of just flying characters
Um, Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you know, uh Euclid's Elements was a geometry textbook written by a greek mathematician roughly 300 BCE That was all geometry knowledge until the 1800s when non-Euclidian Euclidian shapes were invented.
The triangle is eternal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Uh, Drezig, thank you for the super chat.
Hi Doki.
It's my birth- Oh my god How am I still not in the game?
Um, oh I'm, sorry.
How was your birthday the moment I select Johnny?
I need to make sure I get get him before Before I need to make sure my SSD gets it Come on, get in, get in Come on, come on, get in, get in, get in
I will shoot them out of the sky I don't know, it would be too busy to collab and give a birthday song.
Just asking for one today Of course Drezig, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday, dear Drezig.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday tomorrow Okay, no, no, no, no, no, I had the faster SSD.
Oh, I spawned in Squirrel Games house Oh, hey, there's Dracula's.
Oh, that's so cool.
There's Blade right here And there's a Squirrel Girl plush.
Get out of here And there's like, oh my gosh, she learned.
Oh my god, what an egomaniac.
She has plushies of herself I say as I have entire shrine for myself
Oh, that's cute.
I'll make sure to kill all these flies
God, what a narcissist, am I right?
I say as my shrine is literally right behind me of myself Oh my god, there it is Oh That's right, you don't oh my god that does that's right you fucking fly
That's fucking right that's right you fly
That's right
Oh Oh shit, they're making shapes again, you know, I think that's Mario's shape
That's right get down Get down I shall get rid of all the flies.
Oh shit There we go, there we go There we go flying is cancelled, oh shit, the fuck is that What the fuck?
Don't worry.
I'm here to get rid of the flies Here we go I found the solution Where's the fireman
Fucker fucker
Oh my god, oh I see you i'm gonna kill your fucking sister
That's right.
Hello, sister Can't run forever Okay, maybe you can Maybe you can Okay
Is You know what oh shit Oh shit
What the fuck oh my god, that's so fuck I died to the tiniest triangle My god How is that possible I died to the tiniest triangle The fucking triangle guess who swapped off storm I swatted her off of a flying character That's fucking right I actually got him off of the character.
Oh my god, fucking deserved.
I told you I was gonna get rid of them all.
I told you.
Okay, I'm gonna wait.
Where's that fucking storm?
Oh wait, not that one.
That's fine.
I got him out of... I did my job.
Oh no.
Oh, he missed.
Thank god.
Thank you.
Okay, there we go.
Get him out of here.
There we go.
Where's the hella?
I hear him.
Where's that hella?
There you are.
Oh wait, that's not hella.
What the fuck?
Wait, you're not hella.
Wait.
Oh, there's a... Wait, he just let that happen?
He just let that dealer do that to me?
Oh my god.
Fuck me, I guess.
He just let's him fucking shoot me in the back like that.
At least we get to see more of the map.
Alright.
I mean, there's not a lot of... I think I can play Psylocke now.
There's not a lot of like... I mean, it's just Johnny.
Not gonna lie.
Is it?
Okay, goodbye.
Did he miss?
I should actually use my turret.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, did not mean it.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Am I gonna be okay here?
That's not fair!
He literally zoned me out!
Oh my god and I'm trapped!
I mean, I don't know if that was worth it, but... Bro, what the fuck?
What do I do?
No!
Play!
Get out of from the bridge!
Oh god, there's too many.
I'm gonna swatch you.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, can I get heal for that?
Oh no.
Oh, let me stand in that though.
Let me stand in that.
Let me feel safe.
I feel so safe right now.
Oh my god, that's fire.
Oh my god, there's fire!
Okay, don't!
Okay, all right.
I don't... They're all... Like, I basically got them out of the sky.
I don't have to play sky characters and I don't have to swatch them.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's blade!
There's blade!
There he is!
Where do I go?
Oh, what?
What the fuck?
All right, we're figuring it out though.
Oh my god, there he is!
Is this mine?
No.
I'm sorry!
Oh my god, there's a triangle!
I have to make sure...
I have to...
Guys, where am I?
Where am I?
Oh, okay.
He's just punching me!
You can do that?
Please!
Please heal me!
Oh my god, I haven't played Psylocke in so long.
Whoa, what?
Hey, there's a hurricane.
Oh, okay.
Okay, my team's got Alistar's Distraction.
It's okay, guys.
My team's got it.
Oh my god, I have not played Psylocke in so long.
I forgot how to play her.
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
We killed Dracula!
We did it!
I don't know either.
I haven't played Psylocke in so long.
I actually felt lost.
I did not know what I was doing there.
I was in the air for so long.
I forgot what it was like to be on the ground.
Dracula owes me money.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
I cast Black Triangle.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there new team-ups?
I don't think there... Is there new?
The new team-ups are only the Fantastic Four.
Everything else is the same.
See?
The Atlas Bond is still here, chilling.
Guardian Revival, Luna.
Yeah, there's no new team-up.
Gamma Charge.
They nerfed some team-ups, though.
It's just Fantastic Four and the Storming Ignition.
They did rework some.
I know they nerfed a bunch of team-ups, though.
Yeah, and Fastball.
So it's like these 1, 2, 3.
These are the new team-ups right now.
Yeah, but Fastball and everyone...
I don't think it's that great, I'm not gonna lie.
Just chuck Wolverine in there.
The thing is, it's either you ban Storm and Johnny or you ban Wolverine.
Cloak and Dagger and Moon Knight.
They buffed this?
Why'd they buff?
Where Moon Knight can become invisible?
Can inject light and dark energy to create light and Moon Knight.
How'd they buff it?
Oh, it heals now?
It doesn't say it heals.
Oh, it heals now.
Oh, I didn't know that.
It doesn't even say it on this.
It doesn't tell you on this that it heals.
Yeah, you won't even know.
It doesn't even tell you on here.
That's crazy.
Maybe it tells you in his heroes?
Let's see.
No, it doesn't even tell you.
Yeah.
It doesn't even tell you on his abilities that it heals himself.
So you have to read the patch notes, I guess.
So that's the thing.
Guys, that's the thing.
Alright, let's do another game.
I want to play Johnny more.
I think Johnny is really fun.
Stop!
I want to play Johnny more.
Johnny is pretty fun.
Look, I got the achievement.
Zacona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope everyone is doing well.
I bring bad news.
I won't be able to tune as much anymore due to me absolutely slaying the interview.
Thank you for the support last time.
Did I make you proud?
Oh my god, you got the job?
Zacona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congratulations.
After trying to play the thing that one time, I realized it was not for me.
I...
I realized...
I realized I was never meant to be a tank player.
When I looked up in the sky and I see a human torch in the storm above me and then I was like, what do I do?
What do I do?
And I was like, it's not it.
It's definitely not for me.
I'd rather...
I'd rather use the power of geometry.
That one was much more fun.
Using geometry.
Well, you can hit people in the sky as Magneto and...
like, as Magneto and Strange.
I mean, and as Hulk, you can technically grab them.
You can...
You can take...
Okay, you know what's...
You know what's fucked?
They nerfed Magneto...
They're nerfing Magneto and Strange, but in the VTuber tournament, Betel...
By the way, Betel is gonna be on day two.
He can't play day one, but he'll be there for day two.
Betel is a Magneto one trick.
So...
I don't know if he can pick up another tank.
I don't...
And they're nerfing Magneto.
And then I was told that tank meta and day two is the finals too.
Okay, and then I was told that Venom and Thor and Captain... It's gonna be dive meta.
So it's Venom, Thor, and Captain America are gonna be like crazy good.
But then the two tank players I picked up are Strange and Magneto players because in my head I was like, Strange, Magneto, forever!
I couldn't pick them.
It was such a... I didn't realize I would be gambling in that, you know?
I didn't know.
I didn't know I'd be gambling in that.
Like, I don't know.
I was like, wow, when would Venom or Captain America or Thor ever be meta?
Apparently I was told that teams are now scrimming with Venom, Captain America, and Thor in preparation for the new season.
And I was like, fuck!
I was just like...
characters in rank!
No one plays those tanks in high elo!
How would I know?
No, Thor is not solid in high elo.
If I see a Thor 1 trick, I be get flamed so hard in high elo, guys.
But now everybody is like playing Thor right now in rank in preparation for the newer season because that's like in 2 days.
Sorry, my nose was so stuffy.
I had to blow my nose.
Sorry, I had to blow my nose there.
No, because there's like a couple of Thor 1 tricks in high elo and they always get flamed.
They always get flamed and we would avoid it because people would be like be like, Wyatt, please play a Stranger or Magneto, please.
And then like...
But now, right now, everyone's playing Thor and Venom and Captain America.
Japanese girl is so fucking lucky.
Because dive is gonna be meta now.
But like, if you told...
Last week?
Oh my god, there's so many.
I would avoid every Thor 1 trick.
Me and my... like, me and whoever I play with.
They would always get flamed.
So like, we're a little fucked right now because like, I don't know.
Like, I don't know how we're gonna do.
I was super confident earlier because I was like, nice.
We have a strange player and we have a mag player.
That's perfect.
But now, because Venom's new ult, he like, pulls people in now.
I don't know if it's like, activated.
So when Venom ults, they usually send people vertically.
But now when Venom ults, they pull them towards him.
So like, that's really... that's why he's like, he's even scarier now.
He's like, more...
I'm not so... yeah, it's...
Yeah, the slam.
Sorry, the slam.
The slam pulls people in.
Okay, let me see if I can...
Yeah, see?
It pulled him in now.
So like, his like, his thing is so scary now.
So it pulls people in and if you time it correctly, it pulls them towards me.
And then his ult is actually... his ult is really good too.
Yeah, that's... yeah, his dive pulls them in.
So like, that's like, really good if you coordinate that with other... with other stuff.
So that's why people are really scared now.
That above Venom.
And that's why he's becoming meta.
So if you use... if you use Venom and Thor and you combine Venom and Thor together, like, they can kill people instantly with dive.
I know Coney can play Venom, but I don't know if Meta can play Thor.
That's what I'm worried about.
But like, we might not... we might not have to play meta.
We might not have to play meta.
Depending on the team we play against, we might not have to play meta.
Like, we could maybe be able to get away with it.
But like, but we...
I don't know.
We'll find out.
We're scrimming...
We're gonna be scrimming this week.
So we're gonna find out and see how it goes.
See...
Alright.
Yeah, I might ask them if they could try practice Thor and Venom.
But yeah, that's like one of the biggest changes as to why he's meta at the moment.
It's like Venom... so meta's gonna be like Venom, Captain America, Thor, Johnny... sorry, Human Torch.
I always call him... I know him by first name basis, guys.
I'm in the early axis.
What... what Johnny and I have is special, guys.
Cause I'm in the early axis.
Me and my best friend.
What?
Yeah, me and my best friend.
Johnny...
Johnny Test.
Sorry.
Wait, it was Johnny Storm.
Fuck.
What if I just leave?
I've waited so long.
Probably the entire Fantastic Four.
What?
Johnny Bravo.
No!
It's not fair!
I heard Mantis is gonna be meta.
Supports is gonna be Mantis something.
I was told Mantis is gonna be meta again.
And Adam.
Maybe Adam?
Adam is crazy now.
Wait, what?
Yes!
We only have one healer.
That's okay.
Oh my god, let's fucking go.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
That's right.
I deserve this.
I'm the big...
No, I shouldn't say that.
I deserve this.
I don't know.
Luna is all... seems pretty... Luna could be still meta.
It's time to make a triangle!
The strongest shape in the world.
Okay.
Can I break this?
Oh wait, that's not what I wanted to do.
Woah!
He wants to do the combo.
No, I'm gonna kill one guy.
I'm gonna do it.
Don't worry!
The triangle!
I love fucking doing the triangle.
I'm sorry.
It's so dumb.
The triangle has to be the dumbest shit ever.
I did it!
I fucking made a triangle.
I fucking did it.
The course of the Pythagoras theorem.
What is he doing?
Does he not know I made...
What the fuck did I make?
What did I make?
Not gonna lie.
I don't even know.
I mean, it just doesn't help that we have one healer.
Like, this is...
This is a little awkward, not gonna lie.
All I'm thinking is like there's no point in like...
Oh, I made a line!
That's what I made.
Oh, I killed him.
There we go.
Where is he?
Get out of here.
Alright.
Where is the heal?
Don't worry, sister!
Didn't even need a...
They didn't even see me.
I literally was just...
Where is he?
Where did he go?
I don't even remember I don't have to reload.
It's so weird.
I realized I don't have to reload.
Oh.
Don't worry.
I can make a triangle here.
The scariest shape of them all.
Wow!
What?
I got backshotted!
Holy shit!
Okay.
I was like, what?
Where is he behind?
He got literally fucking shot in the back.
Okay.
Please.
Please hurry up.
He's gonna kill me.
Because we don't have fucking...
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank god.
I was not getting killed.
I was so scared.
So scared.
I'm not...
Whoa.
Wow.
I'm not used to using health packs.
Oh my god.
Wow.
I flew up.
He couldn't get me.
He's trying to kill me.
I just flew up.
That's crazy.
Did you see that?
He actually tried to solo ult me.
And I literally just flew up.
What are you gonna do?
What are you fucking gonna do?
Holy fuck.
That worked.
I literally just fly up.
Like it's clobbering time.
Now I'm...
Watch this.
The smallest triangle in the world.
Oh shit.
If I stay in the sky he can't kill me.
We already capped it.
Like what do you want?
We literally capped it.
The smallest triangle in the world.
Okay.
You have to.
That's right.
Oh shit.
I don't wanna get hit by that.
I'm gonna use your shield to heal apparently.
Triangle!
That's right!
Get triangle!
Oh you missed!
That's right!
Wait there's somebody over here.
Wait can I...
Oh you got him.
Don't worry we have a...
The strongest shape in the world.
The fucking triangle.
Watch this.
Triangle!
Guys we have...
Use it!
I have so many fire for you!
Look at all the fire!
Just keep fire!
Okay well he has born again so I don't know what to do now.
Whoops.
What do you do when he does born again?
Don't worry.
Don't worry triangle time.
The smallest triangle and oh my god he's here for his money.
Hahaha!
That's right.
Can't do anything.
Oh shit!
He's pulling me back in there!
Oh my god I thought I was fucking done for.
Oh no.
No my sister is dead.
Triangle.
I made a line instead.
I need to stop making lines.
I made a fucking line.
Okay.
Surely I'm gonna get healed here right?
Don't worry he doesn't see me.
I made a line.
Don't worry.
Surely I'm gonna get...
Surely I'm gonna get healed here right?
Surely.
Oh my god thank god.
Thank you.
I also made another triangle.
That's all I could do.
Jesus Christ.
It's fine.
Wait what if I just...
What the fuck?
You're fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
Just stay in the air.
You can't do anything if I'm in the air.
That's how it goes right?
Oh my shield's gone.
Stop it.
They have double support.
Oh we have double support.
Nice.
Oh he doesn't know.
Triangle.
That's right.
Be afraid.
Be afraid of the triangle.
Oh fuck.
That's so unlucky.
That's like so unlucky.
Okay.
He's not gonna swap me.
He's not gonna do jack shit.
I have another triangle.
That's right.
I have so many triangles.
Okay.
I'll keep making shapes until I die.
Oh fuck I'm dead.
I didn't expect that to happen.
I can't.
When I said until I die I didn't realize I'd actually die.
I wasn't thinking back was a possibility.
Don't worry.
Don't worry I'm close to another ult.
When I said until I die how was I supposed to know I would actually die?
Guys how the fuck was I supposed to know that?
Like the fuck?
You're just standing in my fire.
Oh I can make another.
I'll have to wait.
What?
Oh my god!
He was above me!
Holy shit don't look up!
Cameron don't look up.
Oh my god!
He was taller than me!
How was I supposed to know he was taller than me?
I thought I was the highest!
I thought I was the tallest of them all!
What the fuck?
Okay I was not expecting that.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I don't know how many fucking fires that... Jesus Christ!
This is a lot.
This is stupid.
This is so stupid.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Don't worry!
A square!
That's right!
Don't come in here!
I made a square!
The animal is upping my KDA!
It really is!
Oh my god!
I just shot in the middle of the animal!
The squirrel!
My beautiful squirrel!
I did it guys!
I created the square!
I fucking did it!
Oh my god!
The rare square!
We did it!
I can finally... I stopped making lines and triangles.
I finally made a square.
Oh my god I've evolved.
That was fun though!
That was really fun testing out the new characters.
I feel like that's the only time you'll ever see me.
I'm not going back to support jail.
I'll show you guys my main account before we end it here.
I'll show you guys the main before we end it.
Doki and the other human torch be like 5'11 guys versus 6 feet guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Yesterday I was playing ranked because I was trying to see... Okay so I'm going to see if I can end my top 500 this season.
The half season.
But I'm not like super like... I'm going to fucking waste my time on it.
Because I tried it yesterday in the 3-4 stack.
I got to eternity 100.
And then I was like Oh my god why can't I launch it?
Where's my launcher?
Where did it go?
But like people had to go because you know it was too late.
So I told them I was like if I can't get it today it's over.
Like I don't care that much.
Because the reason why I don't care that much is because the crest is so fucking tiny.
You can only equip one crest.
One top 500 crest.
And like I'm already on the leaderboard for season 0.
By the way we have records now for season 0.
And you can thank me.
I'm going to take credit for it.
Because I was hard complaining about it to people who have connections to like the dev team.
And then I was like tell them to add it in!
I legitimately told one of my friends who has connections to the dev team to be like you should tell them to add it in because there's no point.
And then like the dev actually thanked the person to be like oh my god like thanks for your suggestion.
We had like a lot of people.
We had like such a positive response to like adding the leaderboard.
So like I would like to take credit.
I don't know if it was actually me but like they thanked my friend so I would like to think that I should take credit for it.
Because I'll be disappearing for a second because my game crashed.
It's really dumb.
Every time my game crashed I have to like restart.
I have to change, swap back to my account.
Because I was like what's the point?
I was like what's the point of being on top 500 if it doesn't show your previous records?
Because at first they had zero plans on adding it.
They had zero plans on adding the the top 500 like record leaderboards like previous leaderboards for like previous seasons and I was like what's the point?
So I like to think that complaining works.
I like I like to think that because I complained it worked.
Alright, don't worry I'm coming back.
Boop.
I should be back soon.
I'm not dead.
I'm right here.
I'm gonna take a little break.
So I'll show you guys.
Alright, so bup bup bup Alright Let's see, I hope it works.
I hate it when it does that.
When like, um, if I like for some reason I have to always like, I have to change technically change my Steam account.
I have to log out of my Steam account and log back in and stuff.
Let's see Alright So yeah Here he is.
Oh, not here.
Wait.
Here it is.
I'm at tourney 94 right now.
That's my current rank.
So the reason why I'm like do I do it?
Is because if you get top 500 in season 1 you get a badge that's a little bit longer.
So this is the badge you get.
It is a little bit longer.
I would admit that badge looks a little... Okay, I'm gonna test this out.
I need to know if it is.
Like, I need to compare the length size of this.
Like, it looks a little longer.
I think.
Is it a little longer?
I can't...
Okay, wait.
Don't worry.
I got the comparison image right here.
I got it.
Okay.
Wait, obviously Wait, okay.
Reset.
Yeah!
It's a little longer.
Wait, is it thicker too?
Okay.
I think...
Or is it... Am I like... Okay, wait.
No, it's the same size, right?
No, it's the same size.
It's the symbol that makes it a little longer.
It's just camera angles.
It's camera angles that make it a little longer.
What's the same?
It's the exact same.
Okay.
It was not.
It was all an illusion.
Okay.
That's why I'm not like super into getting it because I was like...
I was like, I don't know.
It doesn't seem like...
Because this is where it is.
You guys didn't know.
This is...
This is where it is for those who don't know.
So whenever someone cues in, you see this tiny little thing.
So, this one looks like with a magnifying glass to be like, what does that look like?
And this is what it actually looks like.
Where is it?
Oh, sorry.
It's right here.
Thank you for the Akasupa, Nick.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Do you see my mouse?
My mouse covers 50% of it.
If I put my mouse here, if I put my cursor here, you might not be able to see it.
No, they do not stack.
You actually just swap it.
They do not stack.
You just...
That's more like...
It's just you swap your badge later.
So, yeah.
Yeah, I need two cursors to hold it.
Anyway, so there's that.
That's basically the top 500 badge.
And the new one above all crest is animated?
No, it's not.
Is it?
Who cares?
This tiny little thing's gonna be animated?
Wow.
It's like seeing a little ant dancing.
It's like, do you understand?
This tiny little thing is gonna start dancing.
And I'm like, I'm too scared to dance.
Alright.
It's the ocean.
The banner ocean.
Hell, it has a good personality though.
Thank you for the super chat.
Hell, thank you.
Thank you.
ShiroDoki, I believe that's totally six inches.
Osni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, yeah.
But hey!
Okay, so...
It's 143, so I'm actually super close to...
So I literally need...
We think safe is...
We think safe would be like 190.
Honestly, 180.
180 would be safe.
So like...
Technically, yeah.
180 would be... I don't know.
160 would be... I think 160 actually.
Because we only have like two days left.
So it's either... I think...
I think 180 would be safe.
And then...
Yeah, I think so.
Because it's climbing not that fast.
It's not climbing super fast.
So I literally just need like three wins or something.
So if I can't do it today, I'm not gonna do it.
It's not worth it.
Like I said, I already got top 500 here.
I already got it here, so I'm not that desperate.
I'm not that desperate because I already got it here in season zero.
So for season one, I don't care as much.
So I said like, if we don't get it today, I'm not fucking doing... I'm not trying.
Like, I can't stack it!
What's the point?
I have one badge.
I can't even stack this.
It's like, I can't...
My fucking cursor covers...
My cursor covers like 70% of this!
I literally can't cover this with my cursor.
You have two badges that I can't wear at the same time.
Who's gonna notice the difference?
They just notice the color.
Complaining works.
Like...
Oh my god.
It's not...
It's not something to be ashamed of.
Anyway, so yeah.
That's basically my current account so far.
Hey guys!
I'm gonna call it here.
Let's start streaming today.
I need to rest, obviously.
Like, I'm not doing so well.
I am not doing so well.
Before I end it here, I'm gonna show a little bit because we have three days left!
Till the pajamas collection ends!
You don't have to buy just the pajamas.
You can just buy the eye masks if you're just interested in the eye masks.
So please, check out the GinaDraws website for a special collection!
Because we have three days left to order!
So please check it out!
The more orders we can get, the more stuff we can make later on because each order basically helps us figure out like, you know.
I posted in the chat so please, check it out!
The more orders we get, the more we can do in the future.
It really does help out a lot and you get a little freebie sticker too!
So yeah, check it out guys!
Check it out!
Only three days left to order!
If you can, you don't have to buy just buy everything.
You can just buy the eye mask itself which I think is really cute as well.
But thank you everybody!
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I'm going to rest my voice.
I'm going to rest everything.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
BYE!
By the rest of the time you'll be playing rank!
I'm not going to lie to you guys.
LAUGHS I'm going to try and get Top 500.
Bye, everyone.
Bye!